let's go to the beginning
how did the American Civil War start and
why so the American Civil War starts
because of our flawed institutions the
founders uh had mixed views of slavery
but they wanted a system that would
eventually work its way toward uh
opening for more people of more kinds
not necessarily equality but they wanted
a more open democratic system but our
institutions were designed in ways that
gave disproportionate power to slave
holders in particular states in the
union through the Senate
through the Electoral College through
many of the institutions we talk about
in our politics today therefore that
part of the country was in the words of
Abraham Lincoln holding the rest of the
country hostage
for a poor white man like Abraham
Lincoln born in Kentucky who makes his
way in Illinois slavery was an evil not
just for moral reasons it was an evil
because it denied him Democratic
opportunity
why would anyone hire poor Abe to do
something if they could get a slave to
do it for free
an economy of effort of opportunity for
him had to be an economy that was open
and that did not have slavery
particularly in the new states that were
coming into the Union
Lincoln was one of the creators of the
Republican party which was a party
dedicated to making sure all new
territory
was open to anyone who was willing to
work any male figure who would be paid
for their work Free Labor Free Soil free
men basic capitalism Southerners
southern plantation owners were an
aristocracy that did not want that they
wanted to use slavery and expand slavery
into the new territories what caused the
Civil War to clash and our institutions
that were unable to adapt and continue
to give disproportionate power
to these southern plantation slave
owners the Supreme Court was dominated
by them Senate was dominated by them and
so the Republican Party
came into power as a critique of that
and Southerners unwilling to accept
Southern Confederates unwilling to
accept that change
went to war with the Union
so who was on each side the union
Confederates
what are we talking about what are the
states how many people
uh what's like the the demographics and
the Dynamics of of each side the union
side is much much larger right in terms
of population about 22 million people uh
and it is what we would today recognize
is all the states uh basically uh north
of Virginia the south is the states in
the south of the Mason-Dixon line so
Virginia and there on South West through
Tennessee so Texas for example is in the
Confederacy Tennessee's and the
Confederacy uh but other states like
Missouri are border border states and
um the the Confederacy is a much smaller
entity uh it's made up of about nine
million people plus about 4 million
slaves and uh it is a agricultural
economy whereas the northern economy is
a more industrializing economy
interestingly enough the Confederate
states are in some ways more
International than the northern states
because they are exporters of cotton
exporters of tobacco so they actually
have very strong International economic
ties very strong ties to Great Britain
the United States was the largest source
of cotton to the world before the Civil
War Egypt replaces that a little bit
during the Civil War but all the English
textiles were American cotton from the
south and so uh it is the southern half
of what we would call the eastern part
of the United States today with far
fewer people it's made up the
Confederacy is of landed families wealth
in the Confederacy was land and slaves
the northern United States is made up
predominantly of small business owners
and then larger Financial interests such
as the banks in New York
and what about the military who are the
people that picked up guns what are the
numbers there so the the union also
outnumbered a good thing by far but it's
a really interesting question because
there's no conscription in the
Constitution uh unlike most other
countries our democracy is formed on the
presumption that human beings should not
be forced to go into the military if
they don't want to most democracies in
the world today actually still require
military service the United States is
very rarely in its history done that
it's not in our constitution so
um during the Civil War in the first
months and years of the Civil War
Abraham Lincoln has to go to
um the different states to the governors
and ask the governors for volunteers
so the men who take up arms especially
in the first months of the war are
volunteers in the North in the South
they're actually conscripted
and then as the war goes on the union
will pass the conscription Act of 1862
and 1863 which for the first time and
this is really important because it
creates new presidential powers for the
first time Lincoln will have
Presidential Power to force men into the
army which is what leads to all kinds of
draft riots in New York and elsewhere
but suffice it to say the Union Army
throughout the war is often three times
the size of the Confederate Army what's
the relationship
between this uh no conscription and
people standing up to fight for ideas
and the Second Amendment a well
regulated militia being necessary to the
security of a free state the right of
the people to keep and bear arms shall
not be infringed
we're in Texas yeah yes so what's the
role of that uh in in this story the
American population is already armed
before the war
and so even though the union and the
Confederate armies will manufacture and
purchase arms it is already an armed
population so uh the American
presumption going into the war is that
citizens will not be forced to serve but
they will serve in militias to protect
their own property and so the Second
Amendment the key part of the Second
Amendment for me as a historian is the
well-regulated militia part the
presumption that citizens as part of
their civic duty do not have a duty to
join a national Army Prussian style but
are supposed to be involved in defending
their communities
uh and that's that's the reality it's
also a bit of a myth
um and so Americans have have throughout
their history been gun owners not AK-47
owners but gun owners and gun ownership
has been for the purpose of community
self-defense the question coming out of
that is what does that mean in terms of
do you have access to everything uh
Anthony and Scalia even himself asked
this question on the Supreme Court you
know he said in one of the gun gun cases
uh you have the right to defend yourself
but you don't have the right to own an
Uzi
yeah you don't have the right to have a
tank I don't think they'd let you park a
tank Lex in your parking spot right I
looked into this I think I think there's
a gray area around tanks actually
I think you're legit allowed to own a
tank are you really I think that like
somebody look into this somebody told me
but I could see like that because it's
very difficult for that to get out of
hand right right okay there may be one
guy in a tank that you could be breaking
laws in terms of the width of the
vehicle that you're using to operate
um anyway that's that's a hilarious
discussion but starting to make the case
speaking of AK-47s and rifles and back
to Ukraine for a second one of the
fascinating social experiments that
happened in Ukraine at the beginning of
the war is they handed out guns to
everybody rifles and crime went down
which I think is really interesting
yeah
I hope somebody does a kind of
psychological data collection analysis
effort here to try to understand why
because it's not obvious to me that in a
time of War if you give guns to the
entire populace anyone who wants a gun
it's not going to especially in a
country who has historically suffered
from corruption not result in robberies
and assaults and all that kind of stuff
there's a deep lesson there now I don't
know if you can extend that lesson
Beyond wartime though right that's the
question what happens after the war I
mean my inclination would be to say that
can work during war but you have to take
the guns back after the war
but they might be very upset when you
try that's the problem no that's
precisely the problem that that's
actually part of the story here I mean
what happens after the Civil War after
Appomattox in 1865 is that many uh
Southern soldiers go home with their
guns and they misuse their weapons uh to
quite frankly shoot and intimidate uh
former slaves who are now citizens this
is a big problem I talk about this in
the book in Memphis in 1866 it is former
Confederate soldiers and police officers
and judges who are responsible for
hundreds of rapes uh within a two-day
period and destroying an entire
community of African Americans and
they're able to do that because they
brought their guns home but underneath
underneath the issue of guns there is
just the fundamental issue of
hatred and inability to see uh other
humans in this in this world as having
equal value as another human being